please leave your message after the tone
hey mom it's Luke
just trying to get a hold of you again
there's some really exciting news I've
actually got a meeting now with a brand
new agent and they're they're really big
like nationwide miss you bye my name is
Luke I'm a star comedian I'm just I'm
looking just for some some work
basically right I really need live work
because of the minute I've got a lot of
death and I've had like some really bad
gigs recently where you know just not a
lot of people coming my family at the
minute are basically ashamed of me
you know I've I've got to make this work
yeah I have a CV I just wrote out this
is just some of the things so yeah I was
the genie and a pantomime tour that's
2007 accents I do African and Welsh
which means I should be you know good
for a lot of places yeah no I'm sure you
are
I'm just really we don't recruit for
them kind this I mean where could you
get me um it would be more kind of
right so that's like like more corporate
gigs yeah type thing and what would what
would I do that like 20 minutes or I'll
write the material you just need to get
just get me in the door and then no I
know it's not really tell me yes I
wouldn't be able to kind of get you in
as a comedian it would be doing an
administration that's my main skill yeah
so that's probably what they'll want me
to do right okay I mean this is like
another way of doing it if I actually
work in you know a role within a company
and then everyone can go yeah he's
really funny
let's not have him working on the sales
floor anymore let's just make him our
entertainment but that that's probably
that's a way that we could possibly work
together as much yeah
get me a job just get me a job please I
just need to get out there
we'd have to do is have a proper CV very
fast to work yeah that's what that is
yeah have you got an electronic badge I
mean if you given like 50 P or something
I could go to the internet cafe
it just seems unfair me paying the 50 P
of its own that you want when that's
there
I didn't cost me anything yeah try to
create some kind of specialist agent
none of them want me no that's why I'm
thinking if you ran the Comedy Store but
didn't say it was Luke McQueen said I'll
be representing Scott Scott blossom you
know they go yeah change the policy yeah
I think you could help me
I really think you could help me dude
yeah cool call The Comedy Store um I
would have to have an electronic cook
with the Seavey's star can you give me
50 P I'm confident that if you can get
me a job I'll be able to find my
audience in whatever job you can get me
get money off your smoovies guys
hey sounds like some swimmers
you